ce très jeune claude béland reçoit la
couture du mouvement coopératif de son
père qui avait fondé une caisse
populaire a autrement
le jeune béland et à travailler et
pendant ses études à l'université de
montréal il se spécialise en droit
coopératif il met ensuite sur pied
plusieurs coopératives ainsi que la
fédération des caisses d'économies ce
qui l'amènera à renouer avec ses
premiers amours puisqu'il fusionne la
fédération avec le mouvement desjardins
un an plus tard en 1987 il devient
présidente du mouvement à l'âge de 55
ans riquet b coin ont compris qu'en
embrassant leurs épargnes faisant en
sorte que leur épargne travail à leur
avantage
on améliorer notre environnement notre
environnement non seulement économique
mais sociale le nouveau président de
desjardins veut que le mouvement reste
un outil de transformation sociale tout
en devenant plus concurrentiel les
guichets automatiques se multiplient les
caisses diversifient leur service et
vente de l'assurance directement aux
clients sans passer par un courtier
le mouvement entre dans le commerce des
valeurs mobilières et acquiert d'autres
institutions financières
je compte sur vous il faut donner un
grand coup de barre en 1999 en dépit des
inquiétudes des employés
claude béland obtient une réforme des
structures du mouvement
la confédération et les 11 fédérations
sont abolies pour faire place à une
fédération unique et il y aura une
réduction importante du nombre de
caisses
l'enjeu était d'améliorer le processus
décisionnel la vie démocratique et de
réduire nos coûts durant ses trois
mandats à la tête de desjardins claude
béland s'implique dans plusieurs
initiatives gouvernementales
il a été des sommets pour l'économie et
l'emploi a présidé le forum pour
l'emploi et le forum jeunesse membre de
la commission bélanger campeau sur
l'avenir du québec
il s'est aligné sur les souverainistes à
pleine possession et le contrôle de ces
pouvoirs économiques constitue davantage
un choix de société et la prochaine
étape
évidemment et a franchi après avoir
quitté la présidence de desjardins en
mars 2000 claude béland reste très actif
de la réforme des institutions
démocratiques à l'enseignement en
passant par éduc'alcool et le jour de la
terre
il participe à de nombreux débats de
société
à la fin il déplore que le mouvement
qu'il a dirigé pendant 13 ans ne soit
pas rester comme lui fidèle aux valeurs
coopératives
on peut pas dire que desjardins
maintenant un mouvement qui vise à
changer la société ou à changer les
choses
geneviève asselin radio canada montréal